All right.
One other clip I wanted to play for you today
before we move on.
This is really funny, but also very, very
disturbing.
Rick Santorum is a former Republican senator
and he often does commentary on CNN.
He may even be like sort of on staff as a
political analyst for CNN at this point after
Tuesday night's debate between Donald Trump
and Joe Biden.
The topic of Donald Trump not denouncing white
supremacists and armed militias came up.
You remember that this was not a good moment
for Donald Trump, and even Fox News said Trump
missed the layup, he should have just announced
them and Rick Santorum.
It's almost inadvertent, Rick.
Sam, talk.
It's not even clear.
Rick Santorum realized it says, well, listen,
it's tough because Trump doesn't want to criticize
his supporters.
And Santorum doesn't even seem to get that.
He's conceding white supremacists are Trump
supporters.
Take a look at this video where he was asking
the president do something that he knows the
president doesn't like to do, which is which
is say something bad about people who support
him.
Right.
Like defining violence.
Well, talking about the was the white supremacist,
number one.
And number two, ask Trump doesn't like to
say bad things about his supporters.
Talking about Trump not denouncing white supremacists.
Isn't that just the best?
That's Republican commentator Rick Santorum,
although I'm not sure how pro Trump Rick Santorum
has been over the years.
I just don't pay attention to Rick Santorum.
Maybe he's been mildly anti Trump.
I don't know.
But absolutely fascinating.
And you can tell from the look on Rick's face
that as he's saying it, he realizes what the
logical conclusion of that comment is.
When you're saying Trump's not going to now
to denounce people that support him, you're
saying white supremacist support Trump.
And of course, they do.
It's one of these.
There's a phrase that has come up often, but
not all Republicans are racist.
But the racists overwhelmingly support Republicans.
And much like that, of course, most Trump
supporters aren't white supremacists.
That's a small portion.
But white supremacists are overwhelmingly
supporters of Donald Trump.
A true moment of candor, inadvertently in
some sense.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We have a great program for you today.
I'm glad you're here.
This is actually a good one.
We might save this one as opposed
to
deleting it.